so
um i'm uh good to be here virtually
the point of this session is to explain
why i came to write the math
fix uh book as you'll see behind me and
what i hope to achieve with it
and i'm particularly keen to discuss how
the wolfram community
can help to drive the changes and
benefit from it
uh you know how you uh
a sense are in the lead position center
stage for for executing this
uh this change so my plan is to take
about half a session
um before starting q a um so please do
line those up as we're going along
and uh would really appreciate a lively
discussion
and uh and ideas as we go through this
so let's start from the beginning here
um
many of you know me uh conrad wolfram
and know of my interest in transforming
maths education
but i'm keen to zoom out because i think
the context of what i
have been doing here and my team have a
computer-based math is
is important so as you know
i'm not an educator i'm the european ceo
and strategic director of a high-tech
company at wolfram
um but as you also know we're not any
company
you know we are the math company as well
from research is sometimes termed
and i describe uh i sometimes describe
my job as computation for everyone
through smart automation
because between my efforts and others
it's it's worked remarkably well
the world is dramatically more
computational 30 years ago
across an enormous range of fields
there's one
massive exception to that uh
education watching how our tech was used
in the real world and not
in particularly high school education
except in a few isolated cases some of
which
you guys are involved with there's just
total divergence
and hence what i call my evening job
uh and the subject of of the mass fix
um and uh just so you see it in person
here it actually is so here's a softback
copy i have a hardback copy somewhere as
well
um and um
which so this evening job is which i
sometimes describe so optimizing
everyone for computation through
computational thinking
and in a sense it's kind of the other
side of the coin
from what we do in our day job of trying
to make the technology work as well as
possible
um so how did i come to be engaged in
this problem
so i saw it emerging about perhaps 15
years ago
but it was in 2009 um that i was really
kicked into action
so as as you know will from alpha came
out
and people kept asking at the time
things like
is it cheating to use it for maths
education
so i did a tedx talk that year and then
subsequently a ted talk
which was entitled stop teaching
calculating start learning maths
although upsettingly they didn't
actually use my title which i thought
was was kind of good
um and we started a small organization
as in computerbasedmath.org to to
investigate this
the first thing was we thought we'd lay
out the divergence
and i started looking around for for
good
curricula um people must have built
curricula that assume computers exist
that would be a sort of opening
assumption computers have been around
for a long time
uh there in in everything you'd assume
that curricula reflected that
um but there was more and more evidence
as we walked through this that really no
one had done this
uh the computer might be used for
helping the pedagogy of existing
subjects but not for
actually re-engineering the subject of
maths itself
also i kept hearing war stories more and
more
you know from the wolfram community from
from other employers
universities from parents from from my
own daughter
stuff about people who got stuck doing
long division by hand so they were
written off as computational thinkers
for studying biology
math from after age 10 not used outside
math
no connection between compulsory math
for 10 plus years
and people's lives after education
these are the sort of war stories that
that kept coming up
over and over again um but really this
was a much
bigger problem even than i had imagined
um we started talking to countries and
going to to conferences
and we put on our own conferences we put
on a few cbm summits uh in london
mostly and also one in in new york at a
unicef
who who helped us with that and
we talked to community and we talked to
educators
but as we went through i just couldn't
believe no one assumes computers do the
calculating
it seems so obvious and changed
everything in education
as it had in the real world realized
what a big deal this was
whole world running in the wrong
direction to catch up with a sort of
computational ai
future and i also realized how much
upset there really
is how much disenfranchisement
you know how many people in education
are put off not only mathematics itself
but many other subjects speaking science
subjects
because of this problem because they're
being forced to run in one direction
when actually what the world requires is
a different direction
so slowly we got some projects
innovative countries
interested and and the first was
education minister in estonia
who who stuck his neck out first and
said you know we want to try something
here this seems very interesting
so we then started building out what
what we deliver
thought we'd inject our new content in
structures of today's curricula
but that didn't really work couldn't use
today's formulation
of curricula in order to inject the new
the new content so we had to engineer
re-engineer that too
we needed a new conceptualization of a
curriculum
to go with the brand new content
the other thing was sort of interesting
is we were trying to figure out how to
manifest
this new curriculum and in the end
after a lot of different ways of looking
at this we decided the best way was just
to build the actual materials to
manifest the curriculum
not to write specs for others to
interpret which is what's normally done
in building curricular you write
you write a long spec sheet uh and you
know
other people who like make the books or
make the course materials then try to
interpret what the spec sheet means and
also so do the people writing exams and
actually the people writing the books
then use the exams to figure out what to
write
it seemed much more sensible to just do
this directly
build the materials and it's also
critical in this modern era because
you can't assume that other people can
really build the complexity of
interactive materials
uh in notebooks in our case that um
uh that that you really want um it's no
use leaving out to a third party if it
doesn't manifest the ideas you've got
so uh we've made good we made good
progress with this and continue to do so
but the educational ecosystem puts up so
many roadblocks to subject change
and maths in particular is so central
you can't touch it
you'd think that because it was so
important it would be the first to get
innovation but actually it puts it
pretty much at the back of the line
because it's untouchable because it's so
central to what many people think of us
as important in education
it's also so ingrained in people's
psychology so ingrained in judging
students through assessments so central
but yet so utterly disconnected
and the comparison i've often thought
about with respect to this is latin
in the uk and other european schools in
the 1950s you had to do well at latin
in order to get top university to go to
a top university for example for science
so if you wanted to study biology at
oxford you had to have a latin
a level which is what you take in the uk
to get to university
and um that sounds crazy now i mean it
sounds crazy that the two
should be so connected and it was crazy
and just like a disconnected math
subject we have right now
is in the same kind of way um but that
would not be true in my
view for the right math subject so
unlike latin there's that there's a
parallel subject that is
sensible and critical for for future
endeavors that require computation which
realistically is almost anything i mean
certainly science but it's almost
anything
as well so amazing thing then started to
happen
we laid out this case we thought about
it we built these materials we've shown
people we said you know we've got to fix
maths but people said much of what
you're saying is not just maths
there are major other problems for ai
for the ai age across
across all education too you know
how humans interact with our future ai
our machines
and how they keep in charge
how you learn to manage the machinery
the ai is actually a crucial part of
education it's not being captured
uh in any of the rest of it and
in sense the issue is to try and
optimize what you're doing with respect
to the machine to get the best outcome
so it was clear from all this that
wholesale change was required around
maths from vision
to build out to process and to the
politics of actually trying to make this
change
so talking to educational establishment
wasn't going to cut it in most countries
you can't make the change without public
support first too much political capital
is needed too little knowledge of real
uses of maths you know too many moving
parts
some of the public need to understand
the problem and see a solution
and that's not easy it took me 15 or so
years
you know and uniquely we're in the right
in the middle of this one with millions
of maths customers from every field and
all seven continents in space we're also
employers of maths people
and and users ourselves and as i said at
the beginning
we're the maths company as as many of
you know
if this wasn't us making the change it's
likely
it it wouldn't be anyone else and so i
felt a real responsibility to
to try to push this forward and that's
really
how and why the mass fix project started
so i've given many talks and got many
invitations
and and you know gracious in
entertaining my ideas from around the
world over the last
decade or so i've written many blogs and
proposals
but but the reality is a 20-minute or so
talk
um can't put the whole argument or plan
together
from problem to fix to ways to change
and so i really wanted to do that
because i found that people often ask
about some piece of this problem and i
say yes yes we thought about these other
pieces but i am really
i can't really put it all together for
you in one place
so therefore five years or so after
people said i i should write a book
about this
i reluctantly started and
the idea of the book is not just for the
establishment so to speak or for techies
but for anyone
um to understand what's wrong and how to
put it right
and i thought i my initial idea was i
thought i'd please together blog post
proposals
sort of smooth it out add a beginning
and an end and we'd be there
i thought i'd done a lot of the work but
but boy was i wrong and i'm sure
many of you have written books have
found the same kind of thing
as i tried to do this i realized the
order was wrong the framing was wrong
worse there were many pieces missing
things we we actually hadn't worked out
uh gaps in the argument gaps in the in
what we produced so
things we we had also worked out but
hadn't actually bothered to sort of
write down in a coherent way
my wife stella thought early drafts were
rather too stiff
not the book she would want to read to
my irritation even though she likes sort
of popular science books
and i realized i also had a personal
narrative in all of this that might be
of interest
i didn't want a dry math book that was
for maths geeks basically alone i wanted
to express
you know my my argumentation my style of
of way of thinking about things and my
experiences
and also my educational failures my
daughter's challenges
my observations about maths and about
life
i looked at a genre as a book this could
fit into and realized it really doesn't
fit into any
it's it's quite interesting that in its
own right there are popular science
books
but there isn't but this isn't science
per se it's it's math
um there's educational philosophy books
but they're mostly about
the concepts the ideas the philosophy
and they're not mostly about the action
um uh um you know but just about the so
to speak critique
um there are also many books about doing
today's math better or self-help books
or ways to improve the pedagogy
so my book is none of these things per
se
it's how to how and why we want to
establish the new
maths subject as a core curriculum
that can drive our populations forward
and um so i've attempted to cut through
all of these different genres
and only you can you can tell me whether
it succeeded
i've made this for everyone who cares
and parents teachers students
and uh and all those who who need to
care
uh employers um policymakers and
politicians
it's been pretty challenging um firstly
this is a very challenging complex topic
uh with subjects or with with many
pieces to it
the details are kind of important to the
whole argument and intricate
on the other hand there's there's clear
to understand stuff about purpose about
the point of education
and um uh
let's see i just want to check my my
camera's still
still up um and uh
um let me start my video for some reason
my my camera went off there
hopefully i can i can re-re-energize it
let's see um
there's some some problem there i can
want to check everyone can still hear me
uh let me fire up my camera again if i
can
ah okay great you can still hear me well
listen i'm going to go on hope there we
go my camera i think has
fired back up again sorry about that so
so as i was saying this has been pretty
challenging
and um you know to piece together the
the intricate details that we need
but also the the purpose in a sense
um at the point of education which are
very general issues
and things that really anyone can
understand so
i've tried to marry these two in the
book i hope i've given enough detail for
the policy maker to get a handle on what
really what needs changing and the fact
that there is a very definite plan and
proposal
in what i present but also enough
readability and accessibility for
for everyone else so i thought i would
just
give you a quick flick through how this
turned out
um and uh so let me try and share the uh
the appropriate part of my
my screen here and um hopefully now
uh you can see all of this
and um this is uh the the
matt's fixed book and i i really wanted
just to pick out a few pieces as i
i go along the way um
the uh this is the table of contents as
you see the book is very much broken up
into
three sections the problem the fix and
achieving change
and you know in a sense that the first
section is slightly easier reading about
the problem
the second section is quite detailed
what exactly are we proposing
and then the third section is is the
practicalities of trying to achieve
change um you know and the politics of
that
um the um i just thought i'd
read and dot through a few sections of
of the book here we're in the preface
um and i wanted to explain why i called
it the math fix the first place you know
today's maths education has become an
unhealthy fixation for assessment
an addictive fix for policy makers to
push and therefore hard to fundamentally
fix
i intended all these meanings in
entitling this book the mass fix with a
crucial extra one added
spelling out the solution or the fix in
detail
so there are many reasons why i've
called it
by the way the the paren s is for two
reasons one was uh
a sort of a joke on maths that it's a
math as a function of the s's but also
because of course depending which side
of the atlantic you are you decide to
call it math or maths as we do in
the uk um
the uh so just to walk through a couple
of things in in part one
um really what i said but but here's the
way i spell it out in
early on in the book you know every
maths school curriculum around the world
starts from the assumption that student
needs to calculate themselves and only
then in some cases if they're lucky
might they progress to using calculating
machinery
at first sight assuming humans as a
prime as primary calculators might not
seem so harmful a misassumption
perhaps even a beneficial proxy or a
requirement of brain development
but as i will describe it's increasingly
disastrous for many individuals and
collectively for their
societies not only economically though
this is highly significant but also in
well-being and perhaps most of all in
governance
i want to make clear throughout the book
that this is such a major problem this
isn't just
a sort of detail of which which type of
math you do this is a societal issue
uh another thing i wanted to bring up a
lot was you know do we perpetrate
subjects just because previous
generations learn them too or accept
that they're good for us like
like medicines prescribed by by village
elders
it's very important people are able to
assess
what it is that uh that they're being
educated in why that's important and
push against that if it makes sense um
and i i think that sometimes the maths
educationists can look like the the sort
of elders the the policymakers like
disciples and the populations like the
maths tribes
and um uh i think it's important that we
we don't come across or
be that way um as we go through i've
also tried to dot a few examples
through the book um it's challenging to
do this because you want to give
a fair amount of detail but not as much
detail as many people in this audience
might like
but on the other hand you want to
overwhelm people but you want to give
people a sense of what what we're really
talking about here and obviously at the
moment
um i did manage to slot in the pandemic
before the book got out as one of those
examples
now a crucial thing we've worked on over
the years
and really refined this book is you know
what is the process of maths or
computational thinking
and how do you progress through it and i
think we have some quite nice graphics
that are actually pretty useful for
anyone learning
maths to have in their heads as they're
going through
this define abstract compute and
interpret a way of thinking about things
so that's a little bit about the sort of
opener of what what the problem is and
and how we should think about it so then
the the fix
and what we do and and this was a
section that took me a lot of effort to
to sort of get my head around um when
you talk about outcomes in education you
don't usually focus on
in a sense thinking what is it that we
mean to
think and how can we set up outcomes
that match that
and that was a major part of what we
what we did and i think what we got a
lot clearer in actually making this book
i think a crucial part of this is where
sort of high concept ideas come in and
as i wrote here maths is losing many of
our students before they ever get near
high concept computational thinking
which might in fact be the spark for
their interest in maths its own right
i actually think we'll end up with more
people interested in maths in its own
right
if we go down the track i'm suggesting
that if we go down the track we're in at
the moment where we sort of start with
this abstract idea first
um one thing i just wanted to highlight
here
throughout the book we have many
connections with mathematica wolf from
language
and what we've done um both inside
wolfram and and in the community
and uh one here was when we were trying
to work out schemas for how
to map what you need in computational
thinking or maths curriculum of a new
sort
against what's out there
we realize that you know
our documentation in mathematica is
really a fantastic
way to think about some of the the
issues there um
and mathematica in general has been a
really good way of laying out some of
the
schema for for how to think about
uh the whole edifice of mathematics
there are some issues to add for
education
and uh but uh but we've done this so
we've actually started building
uh in a sense part of what we're talking
about in the
the outcomes and the sets of things you
really need to learn
uh by thinking about how mathematical
documentation evolved over the years
and how we can learn from that and i
think that's a far
better way than i've seen in any
jurisdiction in any country or for any
maths curriculum
of laying out what's needed in this
modern world one of the things people
often miss in traditional maths
curricula
is that when you've got machinery and
automation involved as we have now there
are many different layers
of knowing something you know knowing
doesn't mean you know i know
solving a quadratic equation means could
be meant on something i know a quadratic
equation
equation exists i know how to set it up
i know how to interpret the result is is
different from knowing how to calculate
it in different ways
and these levels of knowing are never
abstracted out and thought about
separately
in most of what's done uh well in any
really of what's done in traditional
curricula and laying that out
is actually quite complicated but
matches very closely some of the things
that we might want to do that we do do
in documenting mathematica
um another issue uh we i want to bring
up was
was this really about who leads subject
change
and who makes the change and um i'll
just read this bit out one of the
reasons i realized my team had a
different perspective on this problem
was because as i've described in our
work at wolf room we've been involved
with build out
of a wide variety of tool sets
mathematica structuring their fit and
more from language
it's underlying programming
representation language watching how
they get used and filling in the gaps
this puts us in a surprisingly unusual
position
along of course with the community of
seeing a large gamut of the maths
computation toolset that almost
any other groups and and from so many
perspectives
um users makers employers suppliers and
innovators
our experience of the needed real-life
toolset is broader deeper and more
widespread than almost any other group
so this is one reason i was so keen to
take on to take
a as dispassionate a look as possible at
the educational maths tool sets
would our perspective be different to
the work of many math scriptures bodies
around the world
we wondered and i go on to say
unbelievably so
extremely different and that actually
was one of the surprises i had in this
whole project
um the um
so i'll just dock through a few more
things here um
one of the things we pioneered is coming
up with real life problems that actually
work
and in a couple minutes some alec will
just uh flick some of those up while
we're well we're continuing to
talk and uh these are our modules and
here's a
sort of uh anatomy of a module in a
sense
so that's some of what we've built and
some of the ideas it'll see a lot more
depth in that so
then i went on to talking about
achieving change and what's important
there and my
one of my favorite chapters to write was
the objections chapter and
um the bizarre idea the computer's dumb
maths down
and of course anything can dumb things
down if you use it the wrong way but the
point i made here is
that this is perhaps the most
frustrating of objections i faced
because it's largely an inversion of the
outside world reality
and therefore represents the opposite of
what should have been the case for
schools too
in the outside world as many of you are
aware of course
computers have made uh have made things
intellectually deeper
more conceptual you know in the outside
world
science engineering technology are far
deeper because we can compute things
readily and uh
in education the idea that somehow
computers should just dumb everything
down
it seems absolutely crazy um
and there are many other of these things
i i dot through um
the interesting aspect how latin is a is
a proxy in education
when it existed as a mainstream subject
in the uk and europe
and i believe current maths is two and
we should start with
with the real subject not a proxy um
this is an extraordinary issue which
percolates through the educational
establishment which is the idea that um
to summarize what i've said here uh you
know
it's the best way you know i'll read a
little bit of this that uh
um it's evidenced as maths the current
math
is evidence is the best way to learn
because those who do well at school
maths are indeed represented well
amongst the real world computational
thinkers they say something like look
those who get good school maths results
usually end up doing most of the
technology job
the technical jobs i'll point to the
surveys showing that doing well at
school and college math is the biggest
signpost success in later life
and my point here is this is shockingly
screwy logic
um it's a reason why people should take
the cbm modules
that we have on causation and i go
through in detail describing you know
what exactly are you defining and how is
is this a correlation or a causation
and you know or in fact many people who
might have been good at science and
other technical jobs being put off doing
those because they had to be good at
hand calculating maths
um so it's uh it
it's rather an inversion of what should
be being looked at but that's that's
something that i think is a rather
important thing to
to to understand whoops i've skated back
here
um in the in the document rather let me
uh um
let me go on there
um the other thing i as i say i bring up
lots of things about mathematica one of
things i bring up in great detail and i
think this is perhaps interesting to
to the wolf community in general you
know who do you trust
to do your computations and by which by
when i say who
i also mean what and
one of the issues about how automation
and trust fit together
and how it's quite difficult to explain
this to people in the outside world and
one of the problems we have
at wolf from a lot is explained to
people we've put an awful lot of effort
into making computations that actually
work
well and don't fool you and
it's often difficult to explain that
that's what we do but lots of random
packages you know
random routines in python for example
for example don't do that
and that it may seem easy to get started
and cheap but it's actually a lot more
expensive and in fact i just wrote a
blog post
about a such a complete screw-up um in
the uk
over uh over coded test results on my
personal site on wolfram.com
that illustrates some of the issues that
can happen if you pick the wrong
technology
and i go in here in some detail to to
some of the ways that things can go
wrong
and particularly things that go wrong
the worst case is not that they go on
all the time because then it's sort of
obvious but that sometimes when you push
it when you do something hard
you then get a lot of problems and
that's particularly what we're worried
about with
um with setting up wolfram language and
mathematica
and um this was an example we've often
given of what's called so-called the
collapse of significance if you try
uh uh doing uh doing this uh
in in excel and this is a simple you
know take
uh 11x minus two and start with x of 0.2
and repeatedly apply that formula and
um if you try that in with arbitrary
precision set in wolfram language you
find that you get a warning that things
are going wrong significance is
collapsing if you try that in
you know any normal numerical package
like excel for example
it blows up to a huge number and
understanding the difference between
these two is rather critical i think
um to you know having machinery that
helps you
automate in a way that is less likely to
fool you
and another thing i bring up is how our
wolf from language
style of of input has actually really i
think less confusing than traditional
maths and of course of a much wider
scope
so as i nearly end the book i try and
challenge politicians i challenge every
minister of education to have a core
subject startup and change plan
um not just for maths but in general
that taps into all opportunities driving
innovation because right now we have
sort of stuck
ecosystem in education around the world
virtually every country has this problem
and there are many ways i think that
this could be improved
um many other details i do i try to
compare maths and other subjects like
law
and medicine which i think are
interesting uses of computational
thinking without necessarily explicitly
using maths although of course
they do use maths explicitly and
increasingly so um and also
explaining how again mathematica has
come into this a lot in its different
levels of truth values and how those
compare truth values in law another
interesting way in which we thought out
things in in great detail
and that's not only interesting for the
use of mathematica but in general for
how one might think about things and how
this underlies many other fields
um another thing that i i've been very
conscious of particularly through the
covid crisis is how
computational thinking doesn't always
work well but we very rarely educate us
our students in understanding that and
it's critical that people understand
where you can and where you can't apply
maths
otherwise we have a rise of sort of
anti-expert sentiment when the quotes
experts overclaim
for what can be worked out and then
when the answer is wrong when it didn't
work out as they said then people lose
faith in all experts
not just the experts who over claimed so
they need to have a sort of inoculation
against this
by being educated in where you can
expect computational thinking to work
and where you can't and by having such
an education you are not so easily
misled and then i think one could get a
much more
uh sort of informed discussion about
different
different topics in the public now so
just to
say a few more things here the uh one of
things we've launched with this and i
really hope
um any of you who agree with what we're
saying here can come partake in this we
we've launched a campaign the mass fix
campaign for core
computational curriculum change and
really the idea is
we want people as many people as
possible if they feel they can support
this
to to show their support at mathefix.org
campaign for basically these five points
because we think if we can get lots and
lots of people to
to sign up to their agreement to these
that will be hugely helpful
in taking this to um policymakers
and explaining to them why you know
change has to happen
and the sort of change that that we
really need to see
and these are things we hope is specific
enough to have some bite but not
too prescriptive that you know they
knock out people from agreeing with them
who
who would really otherwise agree with
with most of the rest of this
um i really want to finish by saying
what
urgency i believe there is in this whole
issue and i think the covet crisis has
really
brought this out um
in a sense i see this as an issue of
enlightenment you know we had
enlightenment a few hundred years ago
where in a sense reason was hoped to
predominate more
i feel like at the moment there is
potential for that to be slipping back
with in a sense high priests and
aristocrats of
data science in particular but
computational thinking in general
in a sense telling everyone what to
think but the majority people not really
partaking in that um and that being very
disenfranchising
a sort of hollowing out of of the middle
of our society
and therefore i think it is absolutely
in the same way as literacy
became a real driver for progress
uh mass literacy engendered in education
for everyone
so i believe we now need computational
literacy engendered
for everyone uh so that we can move to
the next
phase of human development in a sense
and and our ai age
and um the um this is sort of like uh
um this age for a new enlightenment i
think is in a sense the the key message
of this book and the way to get there
so um that really concludes so to speak
what i
wanted to say um specifically about the
book
um but um i just wanted to let
i'm going to stop sharing for a second
and i hope that um alec
could share a couple of the actual
modules we've built
um which are all in notebooks uh we
originally built them offline but
uh we are also now supplying some uh to
try out online and we hope we will
increase that number of over time
so i'm over to you for a for a bit alec
sure thank you and i shall put the link
to my blog post
in the chat of the zoom if anybody wants
to have a look now
at them as we go along so this is my
just an introductory blog post and i
reckon most people on this meeting will
have
used the world from language before so
you probably don't need to watch the the
basic getting started but we've put
four of our problems in the world from
cloud free to use
and we've adapted them from the
teacher-led resources that
are available on the desktop install
so let's just have a little look at one
of them i'm going to choose the can i
spot a cheap one to look at
of the four and when you go into it
it'll take a moment just to
load up in the browser um
and we've had to remove the teacher and
replace the teacher part of all of the
activities that we do with little video
inserts so this is
yours truly doing little introductions
and we've also added in completion
trackers so that anybody who takes these
can
see how they're getting on and if they
complete all of these boxes
then they're able to get a completion
certificate to show to anybody
who they need to prove that they've done
the module
so all as with all of our problems
they're broken down into chapters where
we go through the problem
we give the opportunity to review at the
end of a chapter
and at the end of all of the chapters
where you solve the problem
we flip the context and give the student
an opportunity to practice what they've
learned
in a more open-ended project so i'm just
going to
pop into one of the activities this
one's about how you spot
fake data how you spot data that isn't
as you expected
so in this problem we're introducing
students to
how they spot whether a coin toss has
been done fraudulently
as in made up by the human or has it
been done real
and the coin has been flipped and the
results have been
truly um produced through
experimentation so we teach them about
partitioning
um and we put in some questions to check
their understanding
and we give them little tools like this
so they can see if the computer can
detect whether they've made up
the coin flips or not so i've entered
some already i've been making these up
and i'm just going to go up to 200 coin
flips with
heads and tails now so when i get to 200
my results should come up and the
computer
has rightfully detected in four of the
five tests that i
am cheating and then we explain to the
student that it's all to do with what
you expect to get
from the distribution of the partitions
and also from the distribution that you
would expect from run lengths
in the random data and we teach them how
to use this distribution
sorry distribution fit test available in
multi-language to
calculate p-values and understand what
that means in terms of significance
so that's just a little intro to an
activity
and as i said at the end we have a
project so this one
allows the student to pull in real data
in this case
soccer data from the uk pull it in
analyze it
and use it to complete a hypothesis test
all quite quickly and all very easy to
do without
the need to do the hand calculation of
the p value yourself
just using the power of the computation
that we've got available to us
so conrad yeah no that's that looks
great and just to point out of course
that these are you know this is a cloud
version it's been
amazing that we've now got these you
know starting to really work
nicely on the cloud uh and i think that
opens them up a great deal of course
there are more
capabilities offline as well um with
some of the the modules we've built and
um
it's particularly and i guess i'll just
quickly sort of flick yeah flick the
same thing up here and then let's take
some questions
sure so this is the mathematica version
and this is what the student would see
if they were being led by a teacher
looks very similar
and then the teacher would have this
version
with some extra material in like being
able to see the responses of the class
and who's answered
to see what they responded whether to
show it with names or not
on the actual questions and their
answers and
all the functionality that we can
provide with analyzing data in terms of
the
student responses and how the teacher
should uh
conduct the pedagogy the steps they
should take if they want to know what to
say
anything technical about what they're
teaching and link to all of the outcomes
that we prescribe
as outcomes of the computational
thinking stroke cbm curriculum
so i mean apart from the actual contents
and the curriculum and everything else
we're trying to build here um
this is actually a pretty fascinating
use of wolfram technology and in
particular notebooks
um and you'll be able to connect between
you know i mean this is offline connect
between notebooks and the
server notebook for a teacher in a sense
using twin notebooks of teacher and
uh and student um
all of that really is very very new to
the world of education and of course
being able to put
very similar materials online uh and
being able to to make those sort of work
interactively as well
so i think there's actually a lot that
can be done in the community
independent of this content just with
this sort of technology we've um
we've talked about um great thanks alec
let's um
let's perhaps take a few of a few
questions let me just
get myself um organized here um
i think uh let's see uh chase has asked
a question here um will there be a mass
fix
live site um um gymnasium
where there are live demos with
instructor and a few students
and to define a problem and set and walk
through the steps to map that problem
into mathematical simulations
and my analogy is listening in on
stephen's live ceo coding sessions very
instructive in a number of dimensions
um let me take a quick stab at this and
then perhaps alex can can also add to
that
um uh i think we want to have these very
much
um one of the issues that i think is
complicated
in this whole business we thought a lot
about is how much sort of scaffolding
you need to
put in place and how much you need to
know before you get started
so i think if you throw people who don't
really know anything about maths or
computational thinking and say
hey here's a problem let's just start in
a kind of
you know builder mentality uh it's like
they don't really know
what to start from so i think you've got
to have a sort of highly scaffolded
problem
to start with and that's what our
modules are trying to do
and then you can move on to sort of more
project-like stuff which of course where
you want people i mean eventually where
you want people to be is they start with
a blank screen
hopefully will from notebook and um
you know the problem they've got and
they are expert computational thinkers
who can use the
tools at their disposal and take the
problem and simply move the problem to
its solution using those tools
that's where you want to be i think the
starting point for that is quite
structured modules
because they can't know what they don't
know at the beginning
and then i think this middle ground
which i think i you're talking about a
lot is is where you have a
a way you can interactively build
something up um
either individually as a student or with
students and an instructor
i think that's a really powerful way to
proceed
it is tricky i mean so to build these
modules which in a sense is us
pre-doing that is hugely difficult and
it's not something that i think
one can sort of dive straight into and
and as i say actually got along the book
uh which is already slightly out of date
um of course
up until covert there have been many
schools where people thought
you really couldn't do remote teaching
even though the
equipment has been available for a long
long time um i think that's changed and
so i think there is a real opportunity
for a sort of live site
gymnasium where you can you can really
have an expert helping to lead through
like a live coding thing that stephen
does
and i really promote that somewhat um in
in the book
i'm not sure we've got quite the sort of
modus operandi of setting that up yet
but we'd certainly like to do something
more like that um
in the future alec do you have anything
to add to that
um just to say that we are working on a
computational thinking project
site and that would be an interesting
little addition to it
um not sure what how
how live it could be it might be a
little bit interrupted for some
particular problems but yeah it's a nice
idea
great let me move on to another question
um
how does the future of core common
standards look
common core standards in the us which
schools or programs are benchmarks
for using cbm um thoughts on gains for
online education during cobit and
if that would get reversed in the
context of hands-on computer-based
learning okay lots of great questions
there
um gosh where do i start common core
standards
look i i think that many of the people
involved with those in the us
that i know who are you know very much
inclined to what we're saying
believe that they haven't been executed
in a way that
is what they hoped mainly because of
standardized testing
being so predominant um now lots of
people argue about whether it's because
they weren't set up right they were the
wrong idea or whether actually
they were a reasonable idea but
implemented badly or whatever
um i mean the reality of this situation
is
i think most curricular maths curriculum
around the world
are about 80 wrong in subject matter
in secondary school at any rate that's a
huge chasm
and the big political and practical
problem is how does that get
changed because as i say in the book a
lot maths is so much at the center
of these sort of assessment and
standardized testing set up
it's so numerical and appears to be so
important that it seems extremely hard
to change so in fact in part three of
the book i do talk a great deal about
ways one can start to engineer such a
change
um you know one of the reasons we've
been trying to go top down in smaller
countries is because
if you want to change the subject matter
it's quite hard
to take off i mean it's very hard to
find
schools that are prepared to really take
the time
to go into this big subject in parallel
or instead of the traditional subject of
mass
because all the students there you know
unless you've got very uh
sort of innovative thinking parents they
they want their students to
get the grades that they need to get to
the next stage which is usually college
and so once on this kind of conveyor
belt and it's pretty hard for any
individual
to break out of that however good the
teacher or school is
so we have a few schools that have
started to work this we also had estonia
that started
to work with us um and i think we're
going to have many more
starting to do things soon but i do
think covert is an opportunity
um apart from anything else you know
many people have had computers in front
of them
they understand remote learning can be
done and it's pretty clear
that you know there's also opportunity
for different time and also we have
uh announcements like that the
universities in california are not going
to use the sat tests as a standard
input and so forth in the future which i
think will spread to to others so i
think all of those are so to be
interesting uh interesting developments
um will the covid progress be lost i
mean i think there's look there's some
good progress in covered i don't think
yet covert has
caused i'm sorry caused by covid i
should say obviously covet is a is a
disaster
that but as as with all disasters one
can hopefully get some good results
too um but i think that uh
covet hasn't really changed much yet in
most places the subject matter of what's
taught
there was a hope that it would do that i
think there is still hope that the
changes in approach will allow that
give that space to happen but actually i
don't think that's really happened much
yet but i i am
i do believe it will shake the system up
and i believe one of the places actually
may shake it up
first and most prominently is in early
university education
one of the very interesting things that
we've had uh and we've only just really
been doing this around the uk
is a whole range of university
departments that have said
our students are just ill-equipped when
they come to study you know science
engineering
computer science economics you know any
of the above subjects or more
and whether they are you know
very highly credentialed from china or
they're coming from the uk
and perhaps they you know they haven't
quite got the traditional maths as well
set up or wherever they're coming from
they're not really very good at let's
say the type of data science they need
for life sciences because that just
wasn't covered
it just isn't covered and so we started
to get enrollment from quite a lot of
colleges
uh interested in taking our cbi modules
that were sort of intended for school
and deploying them in a university
setting to get
students transitioned to the kind of
mathematics and data science that is
required
so i actually think that may be the most
exciting area to push on right now
um and obviously because all the
disruption in universities
um there's going to be more catching up
needed people have disruption in their
schooling so that the
students coming through in the next year
or two will probably have
not reached the same traditional level
as before
so i hope that's some answer to that
it's a very complicated um
set of topics um
let me see uh what else alec do you spot
any others that we should
immediately take here and in the last
eight or nine minutes
um that's uh
yeah i think uh nick white's suggestion
of looking at what kumono khan do
and flipping it into a nuts and bolts
from ground up computational thinking
alternative i think we've we've had some
problems about why that doesn't doesn't
work
do we want to discuss that a little bit
more yeah dude well go ahead alex
say a few things about that yeah we
found quite often um
there are some innovative schools and
i've quite often pointed towards some
lab schools in the states who want to
work differently
um and i'm not so tied to the the common
core
standards as as many are so that's one
avenue we could explore
but the i think the assessment at the
end is is always a
a linchpin um and is always what
many teachers are looking at as to
whether
the curriculum they're providing is is
the right one
so we would have to look at what is the
what is the assessment offer at the end
of it that we could
we could say is is right and is valued
by these learners
because at the moment they don't
understand that they're learning the
wrong thing
they understand that they get their
certificate at the end and that's what
they need to progress
so how do we get that change in the
mindset of the education community
that's the big struggle with us
and so let's just add to that um alec
that we are one of the things
and again i'll be very interested in the
reaction from from particularly
this community and
you know you need brownie points you
need an incentive
for people in a highly pressured school
curriculum you know where there isn't
much time to do anything that isn't
currently
straight on you know uh
kind of straight straight on the
standardized test
and so it seems to me that in many
jurisdictions that you know the obvious
thing is to have
some alternative some additional
possible
you know certificate or or um or you
know
something that that you at least get um
and so we've been thinking about so a
lot of people have asked us why don't
you offer wolf
certification you know you you did the
wolf from certificate so we've been
building those
a lot in the last few months and we will
have more of an offering at the moment
where you can already as alex showed
um get sort of an initial you know i i
went through the module
certificate but we're hoping to do much
more with that
because i think that if people feel
there's some sort of
um in a sense incentive to do the thing
that's something they could present
there are many people who will feel like
therefore they can that will drive them
to spend a bit of the time or it will
drive teachers to
to maybe ask their students maybe
initially their best students to
to want to do this in addition um and um
one of the things i you know as occurred
to us i mean people seeming so i've been
for a long time trying to separate you
know our commercial business of wolfram
and we make technology
from our sort of you know the
computer-based maths
endeavor which obviously we've
implemented with technology but ibu is a
very
separate uh separate endeavor but
actually people have been telling me put
this together
we don't care we just want to use the
best thing and if the best thing is you
know a certification from wolfram
uh that people seem you know because of
course we have great respect
amongst many in the technical community
so when people in college admissions and
things see such certificate that seems
like that would be helpful
so that's the direction we're pushing
him which i think may help
uh isn't the answer to these questions
but that may help um
uh with uh with with some of them and
um the uh i i note a couple of things
here the
um uh the personality of of
stuff i agree is good and important um
and um i think that's an an interesting
point in how we should bring this out
a bit further in what we've uh what
we've got
um any more that we can pick up on in
the last few minutes here
uh alec do you see anything that
um sorry just looking
yeah i'm just going to reply to nick
while while you're looking actually um
does there have to be an assessment why
don't we just build it
uh in a sense we we have started on that
journey and it's now
at the point where we want to get more
um
in front of the of the students using
things like the four modules that we put
online that
are instantly accessible and free to use
so it's about promotion at the moment
now to put it in front and see what the
reaction is
um and then as conrad said we are
building some sort of assessment at the
end
um but it's about building a head of
steam pushing it out there getting some
case studies getting people
actually promoting it and saying that it
is a good thing to be doing
so that's part of the problem at the
moment and that's what we're pushing on
um i notice uh from brazil we have a
question that you know big fan of
of the maths fix and cbm initiative but
it seems hopeless to get anything
in a sense changed in brazil as does it
in many countries
um look i think there are things that
can be done on the ground and i do
discuss these a bit in the book
uh you know they're not perfect i mean
in the end we need the subject changed
and
it needs to not have you know assessment
that drives another subject but
um i think there are great things to do
on the ground
teaching better problem solving using
the four steps
i think that can build a lot of
resilience actually even for traditional
maths
as well as for sort of engendering the
computer-based maths we're talking about
um i think in every country in every
political system
there's a way and there's a way change
happens and it's different
and i talk quite a lot about this in the
the part three of the book
you know i know in some detail how these
things happen in the uk
and it's also rather unpredictable when
they happen
um i think in the next you know couple
of decades
at maximum and i think probably rather
less than that there will be a major
change and i just i mean
not to say i know how this will happen
exactly or when
or how in different countries you can
execute this
but one of the things i remind people of
is in the uk or european context in the
1950s
the classicists were going around saying
latin was the bedrock of internet and
intellectual understanding
and that latin would always be a
centerpiece of
mainstream education or mainstream
intellectual education anyway
well 20 years later it was dead as a
mainstream subject
and it was replaced by a bunch of other
subjects including bizarrely enough
english language which was not uh
english was not its own subject in many
schools
um in england um you were assumed to
learn that through latin which now seems
absolutely crazy but that is what what
the setup was
so these changes do happen but i don't
think they're very easy to spot
at the outset but i think the pressure
is mounting enormously
and i think coven adds more pressure to
it
and as i discussed essentially in the
book you know you let's hope we can
perturb it before the pressure gets uh
absolutely
um sort of overwhelming and we end up
with a very bad
change because what happens in these
cases is sooner or later the change
happens
the question of whether it happens in a
relatively
sensible and organized way or whether it
happens because the pressure's built so
much there's kind of a volcanic eruption
and everything goes everywhere and it's
very hard to predict
obviously what i'm working towards is
the former
but i wouldn't give up hope i think that
there are always opportunities
and we just need to spot them in each
country as we can as i try and
explain some of the ideas in the book
and um and then try and jump on them
when they come like for example a good
example of a change is when
you get a technical minister of
education somebody who themselves
is uh you know trained in science or
maths or something
and possibly these days if they're under
about 50 might even have used
mathematical as an undergraduate
uh or in their studies and so that may
also help us be able to get in contact
and have a reasonable conversation with
them
um so look i think we have to wrap up at
this point
um we will keep of course all the chats
and perhaps some can answer later
we have a bit later there is a an office
hour session
uh i'm not sure exactly when that is but
uh i'm guessing it's in about an hour
and a half is that right
or is it less than that um oh no it's in
half an hour actually
uh is the office uh the office hour
session so um of course you're very
welcome to come to that look forward to
any more questions and comments then
thanks very much indeed